ما هو رد فعلك العقيد على هذه
الاتهامات التي تسمعها أن
الضربات على مخيم جباليا للاجئين أه
تضرب مدنيين وتصل إلى
مجزرة من قبل
الجيش الإسرائيلي مرحبا إيرين صور حزينة حقا على
المستوى الإنساني عندما أشاهدها وأفصل
نفسي عن  الواقع الذي
نواجهه أرى أحداثًا حزينة وأرى الناس
يعانون وهذا ليس شيئًا
ننوي قوله، ما يمكنني قوله لذلك
الرجل دون حتى قطرة من السخرية هو أنه كان
يجب عليك إجلاءك أنت
وعائلتك، كان ينبغي عليك ذلك.  وجودنا هناك
لا يعني أننا أردنا قتل
أي شخص، بل يعني فقط أنه عندما
حذرنا الفلسطينيين قبل أسبوعين من
إخلاء تلك المنطقة تحديدًا لأنه
كانت ستكون هناك عمليات قتالية كبيرة،
كان عليهم أن يسخنوا
التحذير وكان ينبغي عليهم فعل ذلك.  تركنا
الحقيقة المحزنة التي تتكشف الآن وهي
أن المدنيين في غزة يدفعون
ثمن الفظائع التي ترتكبها حماس،
فنحن نخوض معركة هنا للدفاع عن
أنفسنا، ولا يمكننا أن نسمح
لحماس بالاستمرار في الوجود بعد
الفظائع التي ارتكبت في السابع من أكتوبر/تشرين الأول.  وعشان نكون
قادرين على حماية
أنفسنا علينا القضاء على حماس
أينما كانوا حتى لو كانوا مختبئين
في الأنفاق تحت المناطق المأهولة بالسكان أه
العقيد كريوس إلى درجة أن
نريدهم أن يغادروا يعني هؤلاء
100 ألف شخص في  مخيم اللاجئين بحكم
التعريف يفتقرون إلى الموارد
حيث كان من المفترض أن يذهب أشخاص مثل هؤلاء، هل
كان من المعقول أن نطلب منهم
الذهاب، أعني أنه ليس لديهم أي شيء
للبدء به، لا، هذا للأسف
ليس دقيقًا على الإطلاق، وإذا سمحت  أنا أود
أن أشرح لماذا إذا نظرت إلى
اللقطات التي تعرضها فإنك
لا ترى الخيام، هذا ليس
مخيمًا مؤقتًا للاجئين، هذه
مساكن دائمة للفلسطينيين الذين
يعيشون في منطقة خاضعة للسيطرة الفلسطينية
تحت الحكم الفلسطيني، هذه هي  "
ليسوا أكثر من لاجئين
وأجدادي لاجئون أتوا من
بولندا والمغرب عام 1948، هذا هو
النطاق الزمني الذي نتحدث عنه،
هؤلاء ليسوا لاجئين، وهو ليس
مخيمًا للاجئين، أي أكثر من نصف
السكان في العصر الحديث"  إسرائيل لاجئون
طردوا من الدول العربية
عام 1948 لذا نعم أيها العقيد أفهم
وجهة نظرك أفهم وجهة نظرك حول
الدوام وأنا متأكد من أن الملك عبد الله
سيقول نفس الشيء عن مخيمات اللاجئين
السوريين أه في الأردن ومصر
نفس الشيء  لديهم مخيمات لاجئين أخرى،
لكن على الرغم من أنني أفهم النقطة التي
تثيرها بشأن ديمومة
السكان، فهم فقراء
ويتحركون، نعم يمكنهم اتخاذ
قرار الآن، فإن حقيقة أنهم
اتخذوا القرار الخاطئ لا تعني شيئًا
إنهم هدف ليس ما
أقوله، أنا أقول إننا حذرنا مسبقًا،
الجميع في جباليا يعرفون نفس الرجل
الذي كان يمسك الصفحة التي تسرد
الوفيات المؤسفة في عائلته، أشعر به لكنه
يعرف أن حماس هناك كما
يعرف.  أن المكان مليء بما
يسمونه مقاومة موك، كلهم
يعرفون ذلك ويعرفون أنهم
سيقاتلون هناك ويعرفون أن
المكان الأكثر أمانًا لهم ليس هناك،
بل في الجنوب